divisions within the Israeli cabinet
have come to a head again war council
member Benny Gans has hit out at
security minister mmar benir over a
media interview in which he criticized
US President Joe Biden Ben gavier said
America's stance on Israel's war would
be quote completely different if Donald
Trump was in power Gans called the
comments irresponsible we're going to
speak to Muhammad Jam jum in Tel Aviv so
we've heard that response from Benny
Gans what are we hearing from prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu in relation
to these remarks
so Rob this interview that itar benav
the far rightwing national security
minister gave ruffling a lot of feathers
in Israel today especially at a time
where there are increased tensions in
the relationship between the US and
Israel now Benjamin Netanyahu gave some
remarks before the start of the cabinet
meeting earlier today first he talked
about the relationship between Israel
and the US and he said Israel is a
sovereign state we greatly appreciate
the support we've received from in the
Biden Administration since the outbreak
of the war this does not mean that we do
not have differences of opinion but to
date we have managed to overcome them
with determined and considered decisions
now with regards to specifically itar
benav while the Prime Minister did not
directly address itar benir it is clear
that he was responding to the remarks by
benir in that interview in which he said
the Prime Minister said I don't need
help to know how to navigate our
relations with the US and the
international Community while standing
firm on our national interests God bless
I've been doing this for several years
now what's interesting about all this
isn't just the fact that Netanyahu said
this but the fact that he felt he had to
say it this is really going to show how
beholden Netanyahu is on continued
support from benir for the prime
minister's continued political survival
Ben gavier has been increasingly
critical of a potential deal that
Netanyahu might strike to affect a
potential ceasefire in the coming days
and the Prime Minister has a fragile
Coalition he has 64 seats in a 120 seat
knesset here in Israel so clearly the
Prime Minister worried about the fact
that benir has been threatening to maybe
walk away from the government and
potentially collapse the government if a
deal that is struck is not to his liking
so all of this really going to show how
much pressure well increasing pressure
the prime minister is facing at a time
when many say that he is undergoing a
sort of politically untenable uh time I
want to ask I want sorry I want to ask
you about that uh that that pressure
that you're talking about because um
with regard to the the the talks about a
ceasefire which is kind of going on in
the background we don't know a
tremendous amount of detail about what
stage that might have been at and as you
say Obviously there is pressure from the
right wing pressure from Edmar Ben but
there's also a pressure as well on him
from the opposition can you just talk us
through the kind of dynamics of what's
going on
there is a very complicated political
reality Rob for Benjamin Netanyahu right
now because as you said and we were just
talking about before he is facing
increased pressure from the far
right-wing members of his own Coalition
it's marbin gavier for one also far
right-wing Finance Minister bezel smre
who uh smrd who have in many instances
over the course of the past week
essentially said that they will walk
away from the government if they believe
that this ceasefire or this potential
ceasefire would include the Rel lease of
potentially thousands of Palestinians in
exchange for those Israeli captives held
in Gaza they also don't want to see an
end to the war without what they call
the defeat of Hamas so that's one bit of
pressure the prime minister is facing
then you have the pressure coming from
the opposition Benny gance who was a
former Defense Minister and he is a
member of the war cabinet he's also an
opponent politically of Netanyahu well
Benny gance has essentially said over
the course of the past couple of days
that if he believes that Netanyahu is
jettisoning a ceasefire because of
pressure from his right wing then gance
will leave the government gance has also
made noises that um if he believes that
Netanyahu wants Israel to militarily
control Gaza after the war that he will
also leave the government so a lot of
pressure from the opposition from the
right wing but Netanyahu also facing
growing societal pressure just last
night Rob we were at a demonstration uh
outside of the defense Ministry
relatives of those Israeli captives
they've been coming out since the
beginning of the war they're becoming
increasingly critical of the government
and they say that they don't believe the
government is doing enough to secure the
release of their relatives so a lot of
pressure on Netanyahu at a time when fra
its fractures are growing throughout his
Coalition uh he's facing pressure from
the opposition and it's unclear how he's
going to navigate this in the days to
come Rob Muhammad jamj in Tel Aviv
Muhammad thank you very much indeed